miley i was thinking about some of these
songs that you uh
covered like when you cover uh babe i'm
gonna leave you another surprise
this is uh miley doing uh led zeppelin
i like watching these crowds when you do
this stuff they're like oh whoa yeah i
i didn't have any idea you know i think
we started doing that after
my 60th show on banger or something like
that
and um i think you can start to see the
evolution
kind of there because i started
outgrowing my record which is always the
bummer about touring for a year at a
time because you start outgrowing your
album in real
you know in real time well explain that
to me what do you mean in other words
you put out an album and then you go on
tour
yeah because the tour is so long that
you kind of get
sick of doing this sick of it the songs
don't relate to me anymore
you know like if it's a song i had a
song called like
you know i'll never get over you by the
time i sang it live i was so [ __ ]
over it
my brand is authenticity and then when i
feel like i'm faking it
i was doing something genuine but then i
outgrew it so then it became kind of
fake and so then i didn't like it
anymore so in other words
there's some percentage of your audience
at some point that would show up waiting
to see hannah montana
and then they get the new miley and it's
confusing to the audience and confusing
you well yeah i actually was
kind of bad about that like having i
guess
giving the fans really what they want
and i was backstage with paul
simon for i think snl 40 something like
that
and he was asking me about my set and he
didn't know any of the songs in my set
and he was like you gotta do the hits
he's like for your whole show
it's going to be 90 minutes you're going
to sing one song that you like
and the rest you want to make sure that
everyone that paid money to come see you
love
and then i i think i added in wrecking
ball like the next day
a hard thing i had with it was was some
of my audience was so attached to
a character which wasn't me so then that
does a lot of psychological stuff where
it's like
am i valuable as myself okay here's the
whole show's premise was that
when i had my normal hair and looked
like myself
no one gave a [ __ ] about me and then
when i got all dolled up
and put a wig on all of a sudden i was
like
this you know i'm being chased by
people chasing my tour bus and so that's
a little oh that's a lot to put on
a kid to go when you're yourself no one
gives a [ __ ]
but then when they go and kind of groom
you
to to look like something else something
that you're not and you're really young
and it's a lot of makeup and
you know wigs and all this stuff it does
something psychologically i'm not mad
about it i know how to lay down a wig
like nobody else's business like
i thought i learned but i actually
thought about this a lot this week
because my
hair is some sort of like reflection for
my sanity my sexuality my sobriety the
public really makes my hair
i guess the kind of monitor of how i'm
doing
and it's really not their fault that
they associate my hair and my identity
and my well-being so closely because
i basically we drilled that into their
brains for
eight years of a series